staying with events in Berlin in
political opponents of the German
Chancellor have seized upon the attack
they're blaming Angela Merkel's
open-door migrant policy for the attack
well how mrs. Merkel now responds to the
atrocity could fundamentally affect her
leadership and the outcome of German
elections next year I'm joined now from
Dusseldorf two men outs executive
director of the human security center in
a very good evening to you well what's
your assessment of how much trouble to
reach - excuse me Angela Merkel could be
in well I think it depends a lot on how
she's going to respond to this attack I
think the best thing that she can do is
to you know to to deal with this and in
all honesty and straightforwardness that
she has because if she doesn't if she
somewhat revered survivors or denies the
threats that we're dealing with then
it's absolutely certain that there are
groups in Germany that will try to to
capitalize on the horrific atrocity that
we've seen yesterday and that will
undermine her leadership well let me put
those words to you from Chancellor
Merkel herself saying it would be hard
to bear and clearly the investigation
continues in the search for whoever
carried this out continues but she said
it would be hard to bear if it were
found to be a refugee behind it all it
would be hard about for their German
public - yes I mean Germany has
graciously welcomed the very large
number of people many of them who
haven't been going through a you know a
proper vetting and registration process
and I think it was it would really have
a bad effect not just on the political
discourse but also on society as a whole
if it turns out to be a refugee and
that's let's not forget this wouldn't be
the first time I mean previous attacks
that happen to Germany yeah I'm
referring for instance to the attack and
verts bourguignon spa and they were
carried out by refugees and other
attacks that have been prevented while
also linked to refugees so this wouldn't
be the first time obviously the most
horrific one so far with a huge
symbolism a few days before Christmas
attacking the christmas market i mean
christmas markets are a very beloved
german tradition
you know where people go with their
families and their friends have a good
time to forget about about the ills of
the world and then to go there and can
holiness of people they would have a
very bad effect on the country so what
does she need to do in terms of the
response in your estimation to prove to
the German people that they are safe
under her leadership we're obviously in
the early stages of mourning and we hear
and see these these protestations these
affirmations of solidarity not just in
Germany from our own country and others
but ultimately I guess that's not going
to be enough no I mean I would
personally argue that it was pretty
disdainful of some some of her opponents
of pointing at her straight away before
the blood of the victims had been wiped
off the streets I mean first and
foremost we have to to blame those who
actually carried out the attack before
we blame anyone else but that said yes
she she needs to find clear word she
needs to engage in honest debate and she
has to net the German public know that
she takes seriously the legitimate
concerns that some people have if you're
not in a large number of people you know
there will be people among them that do
not come with good intentions to be very
foolish to assume that all of them come
with good intention and we need to talk
about this very openly and we have to
admit the Islamist ideology behind this
I mean you know these limits ideology is
what connects at all it connects the
attacks and knees in France and in Paris
in in Jerusalem in in Jakarta in Baghdad
and now in Berlin and we have to address
this ideology we we cannot deny that it
has somewhat something to do with Islam
and if she is not prepared to do that
and other people would take over the
discourse and it will be very ugly so
would she have to have a very different
response from 2015 if she were tested
again by large numbers of people trying
to seek refuge or indeed migrate
freakanomics
into germany the as we know the conflict
in Syria is very far from over and so
many problems elsewhere yes I mean the
fall of Aleppo will probably just
reinforce many of the problems that
we've been facing it will drive more
young men and sea arms of terrorist
organization
we'll bring more refugees to our shores
and I think one lesson that we we need
to learn from from all of this is that
it isn't so much the problem that we are
helping people in need but that we need
some due process and some of the the
biggest criticism leveled against her
was basically taking in these people
without proper registration and I think
that's something we need to look at very
hard you know at least minimize the
threat because let's be clear we cannot
eradicate a threat these people have to
be lucky once we have to be lucky all
the time and that is something that we
just cannot change so is that your
assessment then that it's just really
she needs to change the the discourse
but does she actually need to do
practical things like up the visible
security well you know it is a bit of a
trade-off obviously always you know
Liberty versus security and there are
there are things that you could still do
but on the other hand we have to be
absolutely clear I mean thatís what they
want right they want to take away our
liberties and I want to think of a way
all the fun that we have and you know if
you if you have more police presence at
Christmas markers than Santa Clauses at
some point then you know that the whole
sort of meaning more Christmas markets
get lost so it's a very fine line that
we have to walk when it comes to these
issues and as I said before there is
never 100% security you can just take
measures to minimize the risk and one
one one of these measures would be to
you know if you take a large numbers of
people into your country to do this
would you do per process okay Julie LAN
it's very good to get your thoughts
thank you very much indeed for joining
us here on Spike